from tomorrow the 2-meter social
distancing rule will be replaced with a
1 meter plus measure where 2 meters is
impossible and in addition to that
they'll be recommended safety measures
such as face coverings increased hygiene
and changes to business layouts social
gatherings will also be different as two
households will be able to meet
regardless of size indoors and outdoors
so things for example like dinner
parties will be allowed and overnight
stays as well a long list of businesses
will reopen including restaurants pubs
and cafes but safety measures will mean
minimal staff and customer contact table
service and taking customers contact
details to help with any tracing in case
of an outbreak the tourism industry gets
a welcome boost too as hotels BM B's
holiday homes and campsites open their
doors with extra measures in place to
keep shared facilities clean and safe
and there'll be plenty of cultural and
leisure options available with the
return of indoor venues such as museums
galleries cinemas amusement arcades and
even fun fairs playgrounds libraries and
community centers have also got the
green light as have hairdressers where
staff will have to wear visors places of
worship will also be able to reopen
again for prayers and services such as
weddings which will see a 30-person
limit so what remains closed well quite
a long list nightclubs indoor gyms nail
bars sparse bowling alleys indoor
swimming pools as well and water parks
will all have to wait a little bit
longer before they're allowed to reopen